in johannesburg in june the daily low
temperature is usually around 3 degrees
celsius and the daily high temperature
is around 18 degrees celsius the
temperature is typically halfway between
the daily high and the daily low at both
10 a.m and 10 p.m and the highest
temperatures are in the afternoon we'll
write a trigonometric function that
models the temperature capital t in
johannesburg lower case t hours after
midnight so let's see if we can start to
think about what a graph might look like
of all of this
so this let's say this is our
temperature axis in celsius degrees
so that is temperature
temperature and i'm actually going to
first i'm going to do two different
functions
so that's my temperature axis and then
this right over here
is my time in hours
so
that's lower case t
time in hours
and let's think about the range of
temperatures so the daily low
temperature is around 3 degrees celsius
so let's actually the high is 18. so
let's make this right over here 18.
this right over here is 3. and we can
also think about the midpoint between 18
and 3 that we hit at both 10 am and 10
pm 18 plus 3 is 21 divided by 2 is 10.5
so the midpoint or we could say the
midline of our trigonometric function is
going to be 10.5
degrees celsius so let's
let me
draw the midline so we're going to
essentially oscillate around this right
over here
we're going to oscillate around this
the daily high is around 18 degrees
celsius
the daily highs around 18 degrees
celsius and the daily low is around 3
degrees
the 3
degrees celsius just like that so we're
going to oscillate around this midline
we're going to hit the lows and the
highs now to simplify things because we
hit this 10.5 degrees at 10 a.m and 10
p.m
to simplify this i'm i'm not going to
tackle their question that they want
immediately the hour in terms of t hours
after midnight i'm going to define a new
function f of t
f of lowercase t which is equal to
the temperature
temperature in johannesburg where we're
assuming everything is in johannesburg
temperature
t
hours
after
i'm going to say 2 hours after 10 a.m
and the reason why i'm picking 10 a.m is
because we know that the temperature is
right at the midline at 10 am t hours
after
a.m
because if i want to graph f of t at t
equals 0 that means we're at 10 am that
means that we're halfway between they
tell us we're halfway between the daily
low and the daily high
now what is the period of this
trigonometric function going to be well
after 24 hours we're back to we're back
we're going to be back to 10 a.m so our
period is going to be 24 hours so let me
put 24 hours there and then this is
halfway is 12 hours so what happens
after 12 hours after 12 hours we're back
at 10 pm
where we're back at the midway between
our lows and our highs and then after 24
hours we're back at 10 a.m again so
those are going to be points on f of t
and now let's think about what will
happen as we go beyond as we start at 10
a.m and go forward so if we go start at
10 a.m and go forward they tell us that
the hottest part the hottest part the
highest temperatures are in the
afternoon the afternoon is going to be
around here so we should be going up in
temperature and the highest point is
actually going to be halfway between
these two so it's going to be
six hours after 10 a.m which is 4 p.m so
that's going to be the high at 4 pm so
let me draw a curve draw our curve like
this
so it'll look like
it look like this
and then our low so now we're at 10 pm
and then you go six hours after 10 p.m
you're now at 4 00 a.m which is going to
be the low this is 18 hours after 10 a.m
after 10 a.m you're going to be at your
low temperature
roughly right over there
and your curve
your curve will look something
something like this so what would be
before we even try to model t of t let's
let's what would be an expression and
obviously we keep going we keep going
like that and we could even go you know
hours before 10 a.m this is obviously
just keeps on cycling on and on and on
forever
now what would be an expression for f of
t and i encourage you once again to
pause the video and try to think about
that
well one thing that you say well you say
this could be a sine or a cosine
function actually you could model it
with either of them but it's always
easier to do the simplest one which
which function is essentially at its
midline at its midline when when the
argument to the function is zero
well the sine of zero is zero and if we
didn't shift this function up or down
the midline of just a sine function
without it being shifted is is zero so
sine of zero is zero and then sine
begins to increase and oscillate like
this so
it feels like
sine
is a good candidate to model it with
once again you could model it with
either but i have a feeling this is
going to be a little bit simpler now
let's think about the amplitude well how
much do we vary what's our maximum
variance from our midline so here we are
7.5 above our midline here we are 7.5
below our midline so our amplitude is
7.5 and actually let me just do that in
a different color just so you see where
things are coming from
so this is 7.5
this is 7.5 so our amplitude looks like
it's 7.5
and now what is our period
well we are we've already talked about
it our period is 24
24 hours this distance right over here
is 24 hours which makes complete sense
after 24 hours you've got the same point
in the day
so
we would divide 2 pi by the period
divided by 24 times t and if you forget
hey you know divide 2 pi by the period
here
you could just remind yourself that what
our what t value will make us go from so
when t is equal to 0 the whole argument
to the sine function is going to be 0
that's when we're over here and then
when t is equal to 24 the whole argument
is going to be 2 pi so we would have
made one rotation around the unit circle
if we think about the input into the
sine function
now we're almost done if i were to just
graph this this would be this would be
have a midline around zero but we see
that we've shifted
we've shifted everything up by 10.5
so we have to shift everything up
by 10.5
now this is we've just successfully
modeled it and we could simplify a
little bit we could write this as pi
over 12 instead of 2 pi over 24 but this
right over here models the temperature
in johannesburg t hours after 10 a.m
after 10 a.m that's not what they wanted
they want us to model they want us to
model the temperature t
hours
after midnight
so what would t of t be we're going to
have to shift this a little bit so let's
just think about it let me just write it
out so t of t
so t of t
this is now we're modeling t hours after
after midnight so we're going to have
the same amplitude we're just going to
have the same variance from the midline
so it's going to be 7.5
times sine
of i'm just going to do the same color
so you see what i'm changing and not
changing times the sine
of
instead of 2 pi over 24 i'll just write
pi
over 12. instead of writing t i'm going
to shift t either to the to the right or
the left actually you could shift in
either direction because this is a
periodic function we have to think about
how much we're shifting it
so t is going to be plus or minus
something right over here i'm going to
shift it
plus 10.5
plus
10.5
now this is always a little bit at least
in my brain i have to think about this
in a lot of different ways so that i
make sure that i'm shifting in the right
direction
so here at 10 a.m we were at this point
when t is equal to zero this is zero
hours after 10 am
but in this function when is 10 am
well in this function 10 am let me write
it this way t 10 am is 10 hours after
midnight so t capital t of 10 this is 10
hours after midnight should be equal to
should be equal to f
of
0 because here the argument is hours
after 10 am so this is 10 am this right
over here represents temperature
temperature
at
10 a.m
and this over here if because capital
that this capital t function this is
hours after midnight this is also
temperature
at
a.m so we want t of ten to be the same
thing as f of zero or same another way
of thinking about it when f of zero this
whole argument is zero so we want this
whole argument to be zero when t is
equal to ten
so how would we do that well if this is
t minus 10 notice t of 10 you put a 10
here this whole thing becomes 0. this
whole thing becomes 0 and you're left
with 10.5 and over here f of 0 well the
same thing this whole thing becomes a
zero and all you're left with over here
is 10.5 so t of 10 should be f of 0. so
if we wanted to graph it we've already
answered their question we've if we put
a 10 here the argument the sign becomes
0 these two things are going to be
equivalent but let's actually graph this
so t of 10 so for graphing capital t
t of 10. so this is 6 12.
let's see so this is maybe so 10 is
going to be someplace around here so t
of 10 is going to be the same thing as f
of 0. so it's going to be
like that and then it's just going to
and then we've essentially just shifted
everything to the right
everything to the right by 10 and that
makes sense because 0 after whatever
hours you are after 10 am is going to be
10 more hours to get to that same point
after midnight so your curve is going to
look so this is going to be shifted by
10 this is going to be shifted by 10 and
your curve is going to look something
like let me see my this is going to be
shifted by tens you're going to get i'm
just going to get it's going to be at 16
hours so let's see it's going to look
something
something like
that and of course it'll keep
oscillating like that so essentially we
just have to shift it to the right by
10. the argument we had to replace t
with t minus 10 to do it and this was
the logic y